fais une j'ai fait une boulette toute
petite boulette et une dame toute
mignonne dans la file pour rentrer alors
vous savez on est là on sait pas quoi
faire en ce manteau dans les mains en
piétine et puis moi gentil je lui dis ah
c'est votre première fois au César il me
dit oui je dis vous êtes de la famille
d'un dénommé ça doit faire quelque chose
quelqu'un de sa famille qui peut-être
dans quelques instants s'apprête à
recevoir un César là elle me coupe elle
me dit non Jérôme je suis la ministre de
la Culture
j'ai en même temps sans vous faire
offense même la ministre vous avez une
notoriété en devenir voilà non mais
vous n'êtes pas emmerdé quand vous
faites vos courses quoi
on est pas prêt de voir chanter à la
mi-temps du Super Bowl c'est la peur